By the end of 6 Underground, almost all of
the characters have gone through complete
arcs, the themes have been clearly stated
and explored, and the pipe has been laid for
the inevitable sequel.
You were probably just too busy watching things
blow up to notice.
6 Underground foreshadows the ending to its
main plot fairly early.
About half an hour into the movie, we see
a flashback in which One is in Paris, where
he meets the dictator of Turgistan, Rovach,
at a performance of Shakespeare's Richard
III.
It's an important meeting.
Rovach's smug attitude convinces One to found
his own paramilitary organization.
Once its up and running, Rovach is its first
target.
The play offers One and Rovach the opportunity
to trade barbs about how tyrants always get
their comeuppance, but the parallels between
Rovach's downfall and Richard III run deeper
than that.
In the play, Richard keeps his brother Clarence
locked away in a tower, where he can't interfere
with Richard's plans.
Rovach does the same thing to his brother
just swap the Tower of London for a Hong Kong
skyscraper.
In addition, before Richard's downfall, he's
visited by an army of ghosts who predict his
demise.
Naturally, it's One's group of "ghosts" who
invade Turgistan, turn the citizens against
Rovach, and break into the dictator's yacht,
leading to Rovach's death.
Ultimately, it's not a bad thing.
The closer the Ghosts get, the better they
work together, the more successful they become,
and the happier they are.
By the end of the movie, they're a family
a dysfunctional one, sure, but a family just
the same.
Despite what One says, he desperately wants
a family.
You get a hint of that early on when you see
that the plane he crashes to fake his death
is full of pictures of his girlfriend.
Even One's turn towards vigilantism is sparked
by family.
He's inspired to found the Ghosts when delivering
medical supplies to Turgistan a stop that's
more about photo-ops than really helping people
and sees first-hand what happens when Rovach
uses chemical weapons on his own people.
As One passes out gas masks, it's not the
mass suffering that makes One reconsider his
life choices.
It's the plight of a few children, separated
from their families.
Ultimately, One accepts that personal connections
make you stronger, not weaker.
After stopping Rovach's reign of terror, One
returns to New York.
He clandestinely follows his ex, and realizes
that she has a four-year-old, blond-haired
child.
We don't know for sure that the kid is One's,
but it seems pretty likely.
Before, One thought he had to give up his
life to help others.
Now, he's has something to live for and he's
even more willing to fight for it.
Almost every other Ghost goes through a similar
journey.
When she was with the CIA, Two ignored her
emotions and followed orders she knew were
wrong.
Three was disowned by his elderly mother for
his violent job, which ended up orphaning
a young girl.
Four was abandoned by his friends after a
heist went sour.
All of them decide to give up their normal
lives to join One, hoping to find redemption
along the way.
Every one of these characters finds salvation
in their family.
After Two and Three hook up in Las Vegas,
Two lets down her emotional barriers and pursues
a real relationship.
Three introduces Two to his mom, and the son
and mother reconcile.
After the Ghosts rescue Four from danger not
once but twice, the reformed thief realizes
he finally has friends he can trust.
6 Underground begins with a lot of talk about
the freedom death provides, but ends with
a monologue detailing how life gives us purpose.
That's not an accident.
Seven, played by Corey Hawkins, has a slightly
different arc.
Seven already has people who love him.
He doesn't join the team until after Six dies
during the Ghosts' first mission, leaving
an opening in the squad.
Before joining the Ghosts, Seven, or Blaine,
was an army sniper stationed in Afghanistan.
One day, while surveilling a meeting, he spots
a terrorist masquerading as a U.N. representative.
Blaine asks his superiors for permission to
shoot the man, but they decline.
A bomb explodes, killing many of Blaine's
fellow soldiers.
Traumatized, Blaine returns home to find One
waiting for him with an offer: what if he
could take down bad guys just like the ones
that killed his fellow soldiers?
"And I will never tell you not to pull that
trigger.
What would you say to that?"
That's all that Blaine needs to sign up.
Except it's not exactly true: The rest of
the Ghosts don't trust Seven, and One constantly
stops Blaine from following his instincts.
When One tells Seven to abandon Four, who's
being chased by the bad guys, the former soldier
rebels.
After Afghanistan, he won't lose another comrade.
He pulls a gun on Three, who's driving, and
forces everyone to wait until Four.
Later, Seven is the one who encourages everyone
to share their real names.
During the film's climax, when One goes back
to save Four from certain death, we see how
much Four has rubbed off on him.
Ultimately, Seven is the one who brings the
team together.
He might've joined the Ghosts for different
reasons than everyone else, but they wouldn't
have become a family without him.
By the end of 6 Underground, the Ghosts have
created a coup in Turgistan.
Rovach is dead, and his pro-democracy brother
is in control.
The civilians have been saved from another
round of chemical weapon attacks.
The squad is happy.
The mission is done.
But it's just the first mission.
As One explains earlier in the movie, Rovach
was just the first name on the Ghosts' hit
list.
There are eight more.
Despite all of the setbacks, the Ghosts made
the world a slightly better place, but their
work isn't done.
There are still bad people out there, and
the Ghosts are going to take 'em out.
In other words: If 6 Underground is a hit,
Michael Bay and writers Rhett Reese and Paul
Wernick have already planted the seeds for
up to eight sequels.
Hope you liked 6 Underground's unique concoction
of mayhem.
You might be watching these movies forever.
"Is this gonna work?
Well...I hope so, ha."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.